hello my name is Michelle Callas and I'm
a professor in the Department of
Genetics at Stanford Medical School and
I'd like to introduce right now a course
on stem-cell therapeutics we want to let
you know kind of what stem cells are and
how these can be used as therapeutics in
addition to talking about these things
and lectures we've also got some
laboratory segments for you and these
are starring a couple of postdocs from
my laboratory and you'll see them doing
some of these procedures so really this
class is for those that want to get an
overview of what stem cells are how
they're being used today to develop
therapeutics on one hand you'll see
lectures by experts in the field who are
pioneering the frontiers of stem cell
therapy otix and then you're also going
to see some researchers carrying out
some of these methods and procedures in
the laboratory so you can understand
what actually goes on to make these
therapies happen by the time you finish
going through this course you should be
pretty up to date on the current stem
cell approaches and it should put you in
a position to follow the future
developments and evaluate them as the
science and the clinical approaches
mature in this fast-moving field